another field in flames as the dry
season in Nicaragua comes to an end
fires are spreading over large areas of
land sophia castillo is furious
she's an agricultural expert and says
farmers are starting the fires they set
fire to weeds and brush to prepare the
ground for planting seeds she says it's
a disaster for the environment you mean
why you not can see that that's the end
right now a whole load of co2 is being
released into the air that has a really
negative impact on global warming and
consequently also on climate change for
Honor's shoot themselves in the foot by
doing this they destroy the fertility of
the soil pollute the environment and
contribute to climate change we yendo al
cambio climate people
nicaragua's farmers are battling the
drought in some regions it hasn't rained
for six months many wells are empty
one on Ramirez is suffering to her
perennial banana plants are drying up
and she can't plant corn or beans until
it rains again in the meantime this
rather modest looking container is
helping her to grow other crops project
manager Sophia Castillo installs solar
dryers with financial aid from the EU
this cinnamon which is drawing at the
moment provides additional income for
the farmer
thanks to this 1,000 watt solar panel
she no longer has to leave her cocoa
beans to dry in the open air that
protects her crops against changing
weather conditions and other harm pop
the stuff into the dryer close the door
and that's it it's much easier than
drying it out in the open otherwise I
would always need to watch out for hens
going after it or keep it from getting
dirty the solar dryer also saves time a
welcome relief for a household with 8
children but a meatus often gets up as
early as 3 o'clock in the morning her
time is taken up working in the fields
and caring for her family
rice and beans form the basis of most
meals here and solar dryers go a long
way towards securing these staple crops
a farming community in a neighboring
area is also using the technique their
solar dryer has a significantly larger
capacity they can dry some 450 kilograms
of corn beans and rice within just two
days
farmers use a hydrometer to determine
when their produce is fully dry that is
valuable information per DL cincuenta
prevent oh I once lost about half my cry
when we had two weeks of rain during
harvest time I packed the beans and the
sacks without noticing that they weren't
properly dry entonces el motivo de la
pérdida the solar dryers are
manufactured year close to the capital
Managua the Austrian firm Kona supplies
the components it also holds the patent
more than 80 such units are already in
use throughout Nicaragua providing
farmers with an environmentally friendly
alternative logo da Mo's our system
allows us to use solar power rather than
Lada fires to dry cocoa beans concrete I
meant a wa la la in the walala area for
example the forest is being recklessly
cut down to provide wood for the drying
process since no one is thinking about
reforestation the trees will soon be
gone Sierra para que no de NOC Savino
one of the most powerful units in the
country can be found at the University
of Leon the forty square meters of solar
panels produce a great deal of hot air
the university's department of food
technology is studying the solar dryers
students and professors are testing out
new farming methods such as processing
dried fruit
drive this way pineapples and bananas
can not only be conserved and further
processed they also fetch a higher price
solar energy helps farmers deal with
other challenges like irrigation
Cristina Lopez is installing a new
solar-powered water pump up to now she'd
been using a diesel motor to pump water
from the well to the fields that was bad
for the environment and came at a
significant cost to the small farm
botany Qatar Kanpur and Oh Seminole Naga
you have to buy a lot of fuel to get the
pump to work and if you work it out we
spend 1000 cordoba on diesel each week
and take in 2000 cordoba for our
products what's left in the end not
enough they may see a spooky SEMA he :
they're here so loud no thanks to the
solar pump not only is her passion fruit
growing her profit is too but the well
can only supply water to one part of the
six hectares of farmland the rest of the
fields can only be farmed during the wet
season preparing the land for sowing is
tough physical work the Lopez family
knows that slash-and-burn methods harm
land all that's missing now is the rain
they've been waiting for in Nicaragua